from timcast.com jury rules Trump
committed battery and defamed E Gene
Carroll former president calls verdict a
disgrace a jury has ruled that former
president Donald Trump committed battery
on Eugene Carroll in 1996 and later
defamed her careless claimed Trump raped
her in a Bergdorf Goodman dressing room
in New York City quote I'm here because
Donald Trump raped me and when I wrote
about he said it didn't happen Carol
testified Trump did not testify or call
any Witnesses the case the jury ruled
that Trump did not rape Carol but that
he is liable for sexual abuse he has now
been ordered to pay her 5 million
dollars in Damages in the civil case
there are no criminal charges Carol went
public blah blah blah this is a crazy
story
Trump said I have absolutely no idea who
this woman is this vert is a disgrace a
continuation of the greatest Witch Hunt
of all time
how does something like this happen it's
been 30 some odd years and now Trump's
got to pay five million dollars what
evidence did they have I guess they must
have had something right
did she wear a blue dress or something I
mean I don't know Trump Trump's not
doing himself any favors because
apparently in the deposition he said
something like he he told the lawyer
questioning him that she wasn't hot
enough for him
he plays at the base no matter what man
it was awesome he said something like
she's not really my type and quite
frankly neither are you
didn't need to say that you're not doing
yourself any favors
no but he was doing us favors he's the
man of the people like how do you think
a jury responds when they hear that
Snickers personally I I chuckle I think
they Chuck a New York jury yeah
he's like he's like oh should I not have
said that they hadn't eat that's crowd
I just don't know why did she have like
actual evidence a jury of six men and
three men awarded her five million
dollars Trump called it a disgrace
what's uh what what is the what is the
evidence I suppose that they saw that
they felt that warranted Trump having to
pay
they said uh former magazine writer was
abused by Trump nearly 30 years ago the
jury did not find that he raped her as
uh as she had long claimed the jury
returning the verdict right after 3 pm
found Trump is running to regain his
president
Mr Trump's lawyers called No Witnesses
he never appeared at the trial to hear
Miss Carol who had sued him last year so
maybe that's it it's it's just because
he didn't defend himself that they were
just like okay I guess default maybe I
don't know
she walked into the courthouse grinning
from ear to ear this is crazy to me sure
she did it's absolutely I think I saw
that the the judge would not allow him
or his defense to post evidence uh in
for their defense online too so he's
like gagged
I'd be curious to see so the other thing
that that popped up was uh was this
story here because apparently I'm just
in the news all the time Donald Trump's
trial juror fan of right-wing
provocateur Tim pool what website is
this see this is the kind of creams that
would be in this jury what is this yeah
they say um where where do we have this
um
a security guard 31 from the Bronx that
he got his news and information from
podcasts he particularly listened to one
by Tim Poole a controversial right wing
time well at least at least unheard
called me uh a Centrist but I'm I'm
curious for you know this this uh is an
international article that says it was
May 10th so but I'm curious somebody who
watches this show must have seen some
pretty damning evidence if they're going
to convict Trump right
what do you I don't know what do you
guys think I I was not paying that close
of attention to that trial I heard a
little bit about it today but I didn't
get a chance to look into the verdict
why they see uh I want to be did you
like sniff his fingers is there a video
of it I just don't understand how could
you have evidence it's this long yeah of
something like that happening they're
like well it didn't happen but Trump's
got to pay her anyway yes I mean like
correct me if I'm wrong but like
wouldn't wouldn't the evidence be
everywhere now then wouldn't something
be out there I would have leaked
something if they love talking about him
so I think a lady said Trump did a thing
and they're like okay pay her I think
that's what happened so then when I hear
that like one of the jurors was a fan
I'm like what
he had to have seen something right you
know I just I just can't believe that
somebody would watch this show would be
like I don't need evidence I will
convict I will I will I will uh agree
it's not conviction I guess you know I
will found libel find Trump liable there
you go
yeah that's funny that he paid five
million dollars to use that line which
one
um
You probably thought it was funny it's
like I'll pay 5 million to say that we
all we all enjoyed it I guess they say
that uh Mr takapina clashed the judge
seeking a mistrial on pervasive unfair
and prejudicial hearing rulings based in
part on what he described as the judge
improperly sustaining objections by Miss
Carol's lawyers who argue that his
questions were argumentative at one
point judge Kaplan quoted the definition
of an argumentative question from
Black's Law Dictionary reading it aloud
to Mr takopina I just I I just I can't I
don't believe it I really I really
someone said that you only need six
jurors to find the person guilty in a
Civil Trial I don't know at all and I'm
just seeing something that someone was
saying on the internet I don't know man
I just think all of this is fake I think
there's just going to be a Non-Stop
circus around him through the entire
election cycle to kind of to have
everyone looking at these different
things uh and to distract away from
anything that he might have to say about
you know the the the nonsense I I think
this country is already fallen off a
cliff right we had that story earlier
about the the border crossings 26 000
apprehensions and the Biden admins like
just release them to the streets so
they're just gonna release a whole bunch
of they're basically saying there's no
border anymore that's great I'm not
exaggerating yeah they said that title
42 ends they will enter this country and
they will be released which means
it's a free-for-all so I see that I'm
kind of just it's hard for me to get
enthused by any of this news where I'm
just sitting here thinking like we are
free falling so with stuff like this I
think people need to I think you're
right I think we're over the cliff and
we need to give up on on any kind of
political solution from the the federal
level however the states and the
localities have a lot of decision-making
Authority Under the 10th Amendment a lot
and I think that's really got to be the
political thing that is embraced this
concept of nullification you know
there's absolutely no reason there's
absolutely no reason that states can't
set their own immigration policies you
know that's not in article one section
eight of the Constitution they have
every bit of authority to do that and
basically well not basically everything
that's not listed explicitly in article
one section 8 of The Constitution is is
up for this kind of movement so I really
think that that that's what's got to
happen is we've got to realign politics
with culture closer to the localities in
these states and then that's who was
always meant to be making the majority
of decisions anyway radical
decentralization that's what has to
happen but not just that in theory it
was given to us by the founders that
power was there uh uh and and debated
heavily uh you know to for the states
and the localities to have this and that
is my opinion what has to happen is we
have got to
bring the sovereignty back down as close
to the individual as possible good no I
just want to ask you I hear you but what
would that look like at a state level
how would that operate if states were
having more strict immigration laws or
enforcing them in a way that the federal
government wasn't
they would I mean they they would have
whatever authorities and and uh
resources at their disposal so like the
the Texas National Guard yeah they could
they could authorize that to do what
they want because why if Texas being a
Border Town uh and it's affected the
most why shouldn't they have the most
say or why shouldn't they do it as they
see fit when they're being essentially
made to Stand Down by the feds when they
have no authority to do that in the
first place yeah that's an interesting
point I I hear you now look I'm all
about like states rights uh and having
the state step in especially when the
federal government is failing to do
their Duty uh I I hope something like
that could work I'm a little worried
though just about
how we'd be able to pull that off
especially with budgets I mean yeah no
it's being no and I agree with you that
the states at some point have to do
something that the federal government
isn't going to step in and do anything
so we're definitely on the same page
there I'm just a little worried about
how effective it's going to be well they
I get encouraged by it because anything
almost anything that's good that happens
happens at this level like you see
States uh like legalizing gold and or
gold and silver is legal tender you know
you see States like there was just a
major victory for the defend the guard
Bill uh in the senate in Arizona yeah
you see constitutional carry at the
state level like you see these different
things that happen and that's I mean
what wins like that could you say have
happened in the federal level in the
past five years none and that's the
point the the thing is the
infrastructure that we're the the
infrastructure I would say well but
that's judicial but still I would agree
with that yeah yeah I would agree with
that the the things that we're
discussing right now are all the
infrastructure is all there it's it's
the way that our government set up
currently so it's really just States
taking the authority that they have you
know Governors getting some balls and
state legislatures getting some balls
and doing things that they decide are
good for their states whether it be
Abbott in Texas or whether it be you
know DeSantis these are Governors that
are doing things that help their states
and other Governors should follow suit
and here's the thing it's not just the
states the localities have this
Authority and and and so when the
localities start to embrace this that
starts to set the tone for the culture
in the state or the conversation in the
state to make a move at the state and
and what we're describing is actually
what the mises caucus is all about like
that's that we're calling it project
decentralized Revolution we're
recruiting people to run for a city
council mayor School Board Sheriff judge
to run for these types of offices where
you can nullify the federal government
uh from that local level for the
specific purpose to nullify the federal
government uh at that level that's what
we're all about we know that we're not
winning governor and Senate you know
like we're we're realistic but this is
what in my opinion has to be done and it
it kind of brings together both the
political solution and the cultural
solution because culture is something
that emerges from the ground up it's not
something they're trying to bring it
down from the top but that it's not
organic it's not real so by bringing the
community together at that local level
to make these decisions and insulate
ourselves from the insanity of the Feds
that I think is the thing that in time
can generate the broader conversations
what's the biggest resistance you would
find to something like that just maybe
like one example of the biggest
resistance you would find and how you'd
face that the cult mentality that seeks
power in the will to dominate
it is the will to dominate because the
the thing the thing that people that are
against libertarian ideals tend to
object to even if they don't say it is
they can't do things that they want to
do that will negatively affect other
people right they can't implement this
policy or implement this this project
and the reason is because it'll affect
other people and so people don't want to
vote libertarian if they can't use the
government to push other people around
whether it be push other people around
by getting uh money from the government
and and having funding whatever their
pet project is or maybe it's make sure
that this person doesn't do a drug that
I don't like or doesn't have a lifestyle
that I don't like the the will to
dominate libido dominante is something
that is ingrained in a significant
portion of humans probably most humans
and it's a very small portion of people
that are like I really am A Live and Let
Live person and if it wasn't for that
fact that it is a very small portion you
would see more libertarian policies
actually in the world because everyone
says they're libertarian everyone says
no I don't wanna you know I'm a Live and
Let Live kind of guy until it comes down
to actually voting as if you're a
live-in let live kind of guy and I just
want to plug one resource on this front
the guys over at the 10th Amendment
Center Michael Bolton Mike maharry uh
and the 10th amendmentcenter.com they
they do this work and they track all of
these notification type of bills that
are happening at the various states
around the country so there already is
that repository and they have sample
legislation on their website that
anybody can start taking to their city
council or to their State Rep to to do
various things from you know a gun
sanctuary where you know the the state
or the locality is going to not uh
comply with federal gun control laws to
the gold and silver repositories to
decriminalization to the Banning of the
warrantless use of surveillance
technology all of this stuff can be done
like once you realize how short of a
list of authority is in Article 1
Section 8 your imagination could run
wild on what you can insulate yourself
from in your community from the feds
I think that if we got rid of party
affiliation on ballots you'd see a lot
of Libertarians in office probably
you'd see a lot less Democrats you'd see
a lot of uh different parties in general
the the closest thing that I can say
that backs that up is that the majority
of Victories for Big L Libertarians are
at the local level and specifically uh
where the state makes it so that local
level races don't have party affiliation
yep what do they say unaffiliated yep
yeah there's a lot of uh local
politicians that we've talked about who
are clearly Democrats but they're listed
as unaffiliated even though they they're
members of the democratic party and they
fundraise with them and things like that
but like you said so I I think we talked
about it before get rid of DNR and L or
whatever just names
and then let the uninformed voters go in
and be confused and vote at random
they'll just check a random box or don't
vote yeah don't know who you're voting
for don't vote you'd see a lot fewer
Democratic celebrities getting on
television saying just go out and vote
this is one of my pet peeves this is one
of my pet peeves right every single time
you see one of these get out and vote
PSAs it is almost always a spokesperson
from the left and it's because they know
the people who are only going out to
vote because a celebrity on their
television told them to don't know
anything and will almost certainly vote
Democrats get out the vote or get out
the vote is always targeting people that
are uninformed about what they're voting
for exactly let me let me give one piece
of pushback here and this is an example
and that maybe this wouldn't work out
um so I remember I was working for
mazdore when he was
um uh running for City Council in
Philadelphia now the rules for City
Council Philadelphia or you have seven
at large positions on the city council
and any one party is only allowed to
have five of those spots so the two
spots are reserved for the minority
party
uh and what happened in that race this
was 2019 is that a couple of Democrats
created a fake third party called The
People's party uh and you know so it
wasn't subject to the to the party line
and yet they got pumped with millions of
dollars and almost took all seven spots
they took six so they took the the sixth
spot and almost took the seven spot
wow
well all right now that's Philadelphia
though yeah which brings me to another
potential solution
what about the idea of I don't know if
this I I don't know about if this would
require like a state Constitutional
Convention but when you think of the
county party or the not parties the
county uh governments what would happen
if the collective of County polities
came together and essentially just
pushed out the big cities to be their
own self-governing units be like you
know Philadelphia love love the the
stuff that you produce for us don't
really like sharing the government yeah
here in Pennsylvania so we should have a
borders with you but you're saying that
we should build a wall but not on the
southern border just around all of the
Cities
yeah I've definitely have 30 feet no
doors yeah and put a dome on top
just forget about it and plug your ears
when you hear yelling I've heard people
uh argue for this right with Washington
DC specifically also with um with LA uh
Chicago as well right separating from
Illinois I I see many upsides to that I
wonder if it's if it's possible I mean
normally I would have said you know if
you asked me a couple years ago will
that ever happen I would say absolutely
not that's crazy but so many things that
I would not have predicted happening
have happened over the past couple years
so it's got to the point where like I
don't know maybe that is possible thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time